Rodrigo Qué tal la Muy buenas tardes
Pues estamos muy pendientes de esta
trayectoria del huracán Ian que ya
estaría muy cerca de la costa oeste de
la Península de la Florida incluso las
autoridades ya han dicho que es muy
tarde ya para evacuar ciertas zonas
donde está previsto que impacte el
huracán en estas próximas horas como
estamos comentando incluso este huracán
se habría fortalecido en estos últimos
momentos llegando incluso a registrar
ráfagas de viento de hasta
250 kilómetros por hora lo que eh lo que
hace temer eh que podría llegar a tocar
tierra este Huracán con categoría 5 hay
que recordar que este Huracanes Ya tocó
tierra en el oeste de la isla de Cuba
dejando una gran destrucción y también
mucho Fuertes lluvias y grandes
inundaciones por eso las autoridades
están pidiendo a la población extremar
todas las precauciones porque insisten
este huracán es muy peligroso y podría
también dejar una gran devastación aquí
en Estados Unidos y ante todo lo que nos
estás comentando Cómo se está preparando
Florida ante la amenaza Y qué respuestas
han dado los gobiernos tanto Federal
como del estado
Sí el mensaje de las autoridades siempre
es el mismo hay que tomar todas las
precauciones y permanecer en un lugar
seguro Especialmente cuando esta
tormenta ya haya entrado en territorio
estadounidense básicamente porque ni
siquiera los equipos de emergencia van a
poder realizar operativos mientras dure
este potente ciclón para obviamente no
para que los operarios no puedan no
corran peligro pero también al mismo
tiempo se están viendo las imágenes de
los supermercados llenos de gente
realizando compras de pánico comprando
agua productos o no perecederos baterías
también porque se espera que muchísimas
personas se puedan quedar sin luz y
también bolsas de arena porque según
algunos pronósticos también Se podrían
ver un aumento del nivel del mar de
hasta tres metros en zonas como Tampa
por eso el mensaje de las autoridades
siempre es el mismo hay que mantener la
calma pero también tener todo controlado
y tener un plan de evacuación más de
tres millones de personas habrían
recibido órdenes obligatorias y
voluntarias de evacuación especialmente
aquellas personas que viven de cerca de
la costa porque serían las que sufrirían
los embates más peligrosos de este
huracán